- [Voiceover] Agent Hunt is
transferring classified files
from the CIA mainframe
into his flash drive.
This is the formula for
the size of the files
on Agent Hunt's drive S,
measured in megabytes,
as a function of time t,
measured in seconds.
Complete the following sentences
with the appropriate missing values.
When the transfer began,
the drive had blank
megabytes of files on it.
So, when the transfer began,
that would be t equals zero.
T equals zero was right
when the transfer began.
So t equals zero.
S of zero is going to be five times zero,
five times zero plus 45,
which of course is just
going to be equal to 45.
And S is measured,
and they tell us, measured in megabytes.
So there were 45 megabytes of files
on his drive before,
or right when the transfer began.
Then they say, every 10 seconds,
every 10 seconds, an
additional blank megabytes
are transferred into the drive.
So every 10 seconds, how many?
Well, one way to think about,
there's a bunch of ways
you could think about this
one is, we know that
there were 45 megabytes
at time equals zero.
Let's think about what
happens 10 seconds later.
How many megabytes are in his drive?
So we can say S of 10 is going to be
five times 10 plus 45,
which is equal to 50 plus 45.
So, time equals zero
there were 45 megabytes
and 10 seconds later there's now
50 plus 45 megabytes.
So in 10 seconds an extra 50 megabytes
are transferred into the drive.
And that's expected,
because as t increases one,
this function goes up by five,
so if t increases by 10, this
is going to increase by 50.
So for every 10 seconds you would have,
50 megabytes are
transferred into the drive.
And you can test that more if you want.
You can say okay, let's
go another 10 seconds.
S of 20 seconds,
that's going to be 5 times 20 plus 45,
which is equal to 100 plus 45.
So notice, when 10 seconds
have passed in time,
when we've increased time by 10 seconds,
we've increased memory, our
memory that we're using,
the megabytes we're
using has increased by,
has increased by, has increased by 50.